hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast please make sure you
subscribe that way you get the episodes
as they come out welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is r.u garbage it sure is it's a
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians or we find it at the
group to be classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
[ __ ]
i'm your host age foley coming at you on
a beautiful day
down here in auntie's basement she is uh
driving around the city of philadelphia
with some of her friends
yeah and some baseball bats uh trying to
find out where ben simmons lives
okay that's good and that's just i'm not
leaning one way or another on that i
don't think it's right but that you want
to know what she's doing
that's what she's doing it's weird that
they waited a week to go after ben
simmons
she said they wanted to give them a head
start yeah all right they were mad but
they're still sportsmanship
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the
ceo of argue guard which he's really an
international businessman mikey
bozo around here so show him a little
[ __ ] respect will you
give it up for kevin james hey gang
uh happy to be here as always please
make sure you subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
you know those numbers are true the roof
true to roof those are cooking
patreon.com
just past 1700 patrons today oh
kids are cooking it's gonna be a good
summer uh you can sign up if you get
bonus episodes at ayg
uh you get episodes of hard feelings
which is a whole different another
podcast with me and foley
uh you get live streams and uh you make
it sound like we speak
french in it it's just us being an idiot
it's just pretty good it's us being mean
to each other for the most part
yeah that's it come to a come to a show
on the road come to a show
and speak english i'm not sure when this
is coming out by the way speaking of
shows uh how about a nice shout out to
our producer extraordinaire who that
uh a little kid we call the magic man
part of the chicago comedy scene
new new york city transplant living out
there in queens
heard of it t-bone mcmuffin toby
mcmullen what's up dudes
what's up dude when i hit the true to
roof cannon gave me the most approving
nod
he was like you've arrived in new york
you did the intro bit well
well nobody that has ever produced any
of my podcasts has been that on the ball
with anything
that was like the quickest response
call to action response it was
incredible
i just i've never seen that before
that's funny that impressed you like
damn these guys are good
i'll also never ruin a show with drops
yes just stories about myself
i'll ruin a show with drops gang that
can either be here nor there forget
about all this business talk
we got an incredibly special
back with us here today i won't stand
for it
i don't know what's going on we got a
little company in the house he's back if
you haven't seen his guests
he's like our first guest our first
first episode
ever yeah from jump street from jump
street back at
some podcast studios one angle toby
bleep that all right
can't give him a plug it can't be going
[ __ ] toe to toe with the competition
back in the day you know gee oh
the ost of the geast all right he is one
of the hosts of the incredible podcast
the irish goodbye podcast on the gas
digital network
and he also has an amazing special out
right now that i
[ __ ] tell you you got to go and watch
it's called life begins
you know him you love him he's a
good-looking kid
all right he is the perfect combination
of being in the zone
and losing it all the time
this kid's been way too many fire fights
yeah but he's the guy you want watching
your six
when you're going through the shaw
valley give it up for mike cannon
yeah oh my god that was unreal i've
never been summed up that accurately
either yeah yeah that's great
i was on the nose so perfect and i am
classic
first guest on every popular podcast
they got an idea who's funny but nobody
listens
to it who's funny but gettable
we don't want to show off we just want
to break in the gym i've always
i always get when it comes to live shows
i'm always the second
month the second installment of a
monthly show oh yeah it always sucks
they do the first one they're like this
is great they invite all their friends
their family whoever it sells out the
next month they get two people that's
exactly they're like last month was
great i don't know what's going on that
and they forgot to hire a photographer
like everything
everything apart even though you dressed
up for
it it's a bar show but you wore your
cool shirts
i know you wanna yeah you wanna get the
cool black and white pick up on picture
day baby
it's comedy picture day i feel like a
lot of that's just great photography
you think so a lot of those shows all
those shows yes
because you can tell by the photographer
how they crop them how many people are
in they can make
two audience members look at like a
sold-out show hey it's packed out here
and
you know there's dry cleaners at
brooklyn there's a couple that covers
your kneecaps on stage yeah
it looks hot oh pretty good mike cannon
also
i've said this before is a little inside
baseball my
favorite my number one person
to bomb in front of
with
we've all humiliated ourselves from each
other you are
you are one of those people that if
you're in the back of the room and i'm
bombing
and i say something about me bombing you
give me a laugh that makes me feel like
everything's
gonna be okay well i mean you are so
funny and so
full of energy that the idea of a room
full of people looking at you and being
like
not for us is instantly funny to me
and then add the element of your
gallagher-esque
sweat piling on the front [ __ ] don't
forget
that comes out of his mouth ladies and
gentlemen that's what i'm saying when i
when i bomb
i'm really i look like you are the dog
from beethoven it is insane his jowls
are going
run run blah blah blah i just think
you'd be running through the yards
jumping over their charles grodin
yeah my favorite what did what happened
there was one
in particular like kind of a classic we
didn't really know each other that well
that's right all right it was one of the
ways we became friends so at new york
comedy club
there is a uh there's a door on the side
that leads into the office and then into
the green room
so you you know when comics come on
stage and off stage usually they used to
we used to go through there yeah we
don't need more but you used to go
through there
and you were in the green room there was
a bunch of people in there
it was a [ __ ] like it was it was a
[ __ ] busy show it was packed
i think i had just been hosting there a
couple of months
and i thought i really had it figured
out you know what i mean i had like
i had my ten i had my [ __ ] uh you
know my opening crowd work bits i had
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] where are you
from what do you do
oh yeah and they were coated in a shield
that it could not penetrate it was
almost like they they
they weren't really there they were in
another dimension
watching me from some space command
center
listen that's that's an elaborate way to
say you bomb
yeah it was like in deadpool 2 when he
was trying to reach his wife
yes through that's great you just
couldn't exactly
yeah exactly and i i put this i
don't take that kind of stuff well i
have a good facade
but deep down i really crumble like i
like you know i know connor's like oh i
don't give a [ __ ] or i don't give a [ __ ]
i
did i stink at that i'm just like
and i was [ __ ] as soon as i started
bombing the sweat just
starts pouring and i [ __ ] walked off
stage and you were in mid-conversation
and i opened that door and i was coated
and sweat and i was like jesus christ i
just [ __ ] bombed so bad
and he just looks at me and goes
it just starts laughing in my face but
laughing with me
well it was it was the best because
you're also like
dressed like you're manning the barbecue
yeah at an outdoor
party so you come like spilling through
the door
and shoving people out of the way and
you're like
the whole tell your brother to run the
store and get hot dog buns quick
it was it was a beautiful sight oh man
good stuff good stuff mikey thank you so
much for being here with us
appreciate it um i'm happy for you guys
too i know i haven't been here for a
while i was in that old studio that will
but this is a this is a legit space yeah
that's great you guys really
carved out a nice little nice corner for
yourselves we're down here
we're trying man we're trying that damn
right feeling it we like it
let me ask you this the other podcast
that you do on the patreon
is that one of the failed incarnations
selling it on a patreon level that's
perfect [ __ ] rebranded that a little
bit
it's kind of funny because everybody's
got like especially on the patreon
they're like this is better than
a yg they're like i think this is my now
favorite podcast
it just didn't have the hook the hook of
a y g yeah
so perfect yeah it works it works it's
all the yellow
it's the yellow that everybody's yellow
pops yellow pops skippy knew it does
that go yellow you never go back that's
what i did and here we are
you make it sound like i was in a board
room like what you need here
hawaiian shirts print i got two words
fat guys works
and make sure he sounds like he's
beating a cereal bowl full of razor
blades
what is going on your voice is my voice
bad it's bad have you been screaming at
traffic
have you been joining the other homeless
at the holiday inn half a block away
yeah what is that this is the
neighborhood
where de blasio put all the homeless
well what's going on with that holly or
do they live there
they're getting out in like a week
apparently but that just dawned on me
while i was walking out here and i was
called
i never put you in time i never put two
and two together
yes i was literally walking i walked by
that holiday in
a thousand times i'm going man they must
have really low rates here
i'm like how are they okay with these
crackheads coming in and out yeah and
it's smells of old feet
man the moment you walk out now are they
gonna are they gonna take that holiday
in
clean it out and then start renting it
to selling it to
other people they they have to demolish
it
it's a bad scene i didn't at one point i
didn't even think it was open it was
like boarded
up yeah and people that's still those
just to make them feel comfortable
right this way homeless people we don't
want curtains we'd like boards please
something to remind you of home now
would you like a sheet or a trash bag
over your window sir what would you
prefer
man because what if you were in there
and you found out oh yeah by the way
this was the death star for homeless
people
i don't even like going to that 7-eleven
it's just crack smoke and aces
there's a 7-eleven around here yeah yeah
i mean 7-elevens in general are just a
breeding ground in new york it's
horrible yeah in the burbs it's [ __ ]
it's the simpsons
it's clean living yeah it's nice but do
you know why
it's because they accept any and all
cards so it's
it's like bodegas are cash places yeah
obviously and you got a limit and
whatever it's like here you could take
an ebt card debit card credit card
whatever
slide it through for a 37 cent purchase
yeah that's true like
yeah there's a minimum at a bodegas
we're not going to let you
scan for 50 cents or oh i never knew
you're buying a beer for a dollar fifty
or something good
good homeless
[Laughter]
i was embedded back in 82 for cnn what's
the what's the least amount of money
you've ever put on a debit card
oh under a dollar oh yeah like i think
like 56
cents yeah when and when and i may have
overdrawn like i used to
i used to play it that day dude i was
really i was getting razor
just give me three jolly ranchers
and a bouncy ball and do you take
american express
[Laughter]
diners club nothing diners club
oh my god this club's trash i remember
the dad then pulled that out like i'll
pay for myself oh
all right buying one you need it one
stick of trident you're like i need the
miles
[Laughter]
i get cash back yeah do you sell fun
stripe gum and lucy's
oh dude me and my friend tim compared
each other this to each other the other
day
because both of our fathers would like
outfit us in things they bought with
marlboro points
so like my friend had like an absolute
vodka like all that [ __ ] like my friend
tim had an absolute
letterman's jacket which then was like
what the [ __ ] are you wearing you're 10
you know whatever but now it's probably
selling for 800 on ebay oh yeah
it's one of those i i hated a marlboro
tent dude like i did
everything that i had was marlborough
it's like a nascar driver yeah
my buddy vinnie showed up to our first
sleepover with a marlboro sleeping bag
and we were all like
oh [ __ ] like dude you got money son
god damn he's like coughing up blood for
this secondhand smoke
his eyeballs were bleeding but i'll tell
you what that thing is packed with downs
he's got the mj eyeballs where you're
like why are those
tan why are they
how long did it take to get those back
then like oh the
ordering something out of the from the
mail for the foley's back then
yeah might as well have been
interstellar spaceship
in my head it seemed like everything was
like six weeks i feel like that's i was
just
six weeks
six weeks i think was back in the day
well in six weeks because
of your small amount of time on earth it
was a higher percentage of yours
yeah so it's like it's a bigger
percentage of your life jesus christ i
never thought about it that way dude
that's how time went through my mind no
so like when i was a little kid since
i'd only been around for like five years
a week seemed longer sure really
dude remember dude remember summer as
like a nine-year-old
yeah it seemed like six years yeah a
summer now it's like we're already
halfway done
i can't believe it oh he's he's done
i'll see you guys later
this guy's got act outs on the podcast
it's pretty good youtube oh my god
uh how are things good you know
he's not at the holiday inn so he's
doing all right well i met my
in-laws holiday man you said you said
that like you were on the roof of a
ramada
yeah pretty good yeah there's days
there's days you know like last night
for instance was father's day obviously
yeah happy father's day thank you
happy father's day buddy yeah you know i
i i texted you you did no this was a
week after
you're right last week was father's day
and uh we just broke the delusion of
time so it doesn't matter
mike just shattered all space at the
time and my father-in-law
for those of you who know me you may
know a thing i i filmed called
uh frank rigatone yeah yeah which was
guns
you know i did them like last april and
it was all about opening up gyms
basically the moment they all closed
down right because it was
and it was based on my father-in-law
because he's that last night yesterday
for father's day he uh
he rose his american flag up there and
then right underneath it was a nice flag
of an ar-15 that said come and get it
so made all family feel real comfortable
he wasn't talking about dinner either
so hamburger helpers ready so in front
of the house yeah oh yeah
like with with beaming spotlights
like on it when it gets dark just in
case any cucks want to look through
you're up there in that country yeah i
mean it's in rockland so it's like
it's weird because it took me 35 minutes
to get here
which from brooklyn where i was living
probably would have taken me even a
little bit longer
yeah by subway so it's an easy ride but
i grew up there as well so rockland
county is kind of this interesting place
where people take
great pride in how close it is to new
york city and they will
never go yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the
same 32 minutes
yeah yeah i haven't been in six years
that's right 32 minutes the west village
looks a little dangerous
yeah yeah it's like yeah they might suck
your dick
my friend actually while he's going with
the automatic weapon
yeah exactly uh my friend walked around
with like you know he wears like a
thirty thousand dollar watch or whatever
because he's secure
and uh we're going for who's this guy
he's he's a good buddy of mine yeah
makes a little
makes a little ghee makes me make some
butter really pushing
by the way is ghee like a karate outfit
no ghee is a
ghee is a high end uh high end butter
it's clarified butter clarified butter
oh okay
so for money he's been saying butter but
he's been switching it to ghee
i like that thank you not as much as
he's shoving it in the conversation it's
too much
no one's going to remember that bodega
like how much ghee i got on there
no one's gonna remember that they're
only gonna remember when it sinks into
the zeitgeist well that's why you gotta
get a t-shirt with like a stack of cash
with just
clarified butter dripping got ghee got
it
got key got butter a little bit of cash
not bad my dad was calling it uh
geech the other day oh yeah i've heard
that you've heard geeks yeah money
called geech yeah how about bones you
ever called bones
i know and my father did i was a big guy
yeah you could never forget the bones
that jack it cost
i remember the first time i heard that
we were in cal door
and uh what the [ __ ] is that i don't
know cal door oh it's like a tj maxx
value city sounds like it's been out of
it's out of business
sounds like a lotion yeah a little put a
little cow door on it you'd be all right
dude and i was a leash kid so my mom had
me on this like red
[ __ ] leash that looked like almost in
high school yeah i was i was 16. yeah
but
i was four because i'd just be like
please [ __ ] and then run into the
highway
you know for funsies this kid's got
energy yeah and my dad
bought me one of those uh super soaker
50s
at the time that went 50 feet it was
yellow and green the 100 was blue and
yellow
so that was like the real one that was
big that could shoot a lot of power the
50 was for like
you know kids that were just barely
scraping by and their parents were like
yeah i guess
and my dad was like it's 25 [ __ ]
bones
i remember him saying that specifically
in
caldor and then he we had to get a rain
check
i've never i've it's never happened to
me since but we got a rain check where
we bought it
because they promised the last gun to
somebody else
yeah and they didn't take it off the
shelf so we had to like go back
they were in when they re-up yeah yeah
wow that's a real dirtbag thing and they
do it we used to do it at
the grocery store like it'd be like hey
soups 10 for a
you know 10 for 10 but they were out of
it they give you a handwritten coupon
for like okay you get 10 for 10 suits
on the 13th if you come back here
because we ran out of stuff like allen
iverson's shoe control yes exactly
hey we'll give you 30 million dollars
worth of soup in 15 years yeah when
you're 45 and hopefully alive because we
don't want you
anymore yeah we don't want you blowing
all this chunky in one day you know what
i mean
holy [ __ ] sound at the super soakers man
oh man they still sell them i know
it's really difficult for me not to just
green light
every purchase you wanted purchase for
my son for my son well you're literally
about to come into that he said he's two
years old yeah you're about i mean
you're in it
i'm already doing it but you're it's
about to get real fun yeah oh i mean
he's playing uh hoops already like he's
super into it i bought him this small
ass outdoor hoop that is like also for
me and the pull
and like all that stuff you know
everything that i get them it looks
very childish but i bought you know like
styrofoam planes that you could throw
lighters and [ __ ] he's not old enough
for it and i'm like
perfect yeah yeah i'll get six months of
fun out of it and then you're ready i'll
buy something new
the mini bike might have been a little
bit premature
sure but i'm killing it in the hood hey
mr cannon shut up loser
you might have invented a new
classification of like the best dad to
have which is like
responsible pothead yes yeah yeah
i think you're right you gotta have your
day you gotta have a little trash in the
dad
yeah he's gotta wanna play because my
dad used to play you know like guns with
us and stuff like that
he was re-living
he was doing barrel rolls off the roof
you're also talking that he was spilling
the bullets onto the table picking up
one spin
and be like let's have a game i'll admit
him pulling my fingernails out was a
little harsh
for a wednesday night but no like even
with like my nieces and nephews yeah you
get one for them
but i get one for me too yes like if i
buy if i buy nerf guns for
my niece and nephew i'm getting three
right how am i gonna shoot you
yeah yeah [ __ ] i can't do the gun you
turn on me yeah right no thank you
it's all like and i i cause i don't i
know i know the certain things that made
me
like damaged mentally and emotionally
you know what i mean so i'm steering
clear of those things
but there are stuff things that my
parents did well and withheld from me
that like made me into a real
well-rounded person that doesn't
necessarily feel entitled to things and
stuff like that
and i'm just like giving my son
everything
right now so i don't know when i need to
stop that um
it's fun to give him everything to have
fun like that yeah right
i mean you know and i'm not like i i
don't plan on just
allowing him to run a bomb yeah sure
you're not just like oh you're
having this yeah it's like at this point
i just want to show that yeah when
they're little exact that kind of stuff
yeah i think around like 11 or 12 you're
going to start cracking down
straightening them out a little bit i
don't know i had i kind of had free work
because my
my parents were divorced and my dad was
like if i could get them in the store
if i could get them on the lot we were
buying your dad my dad
if you came with my mom if i could get
my dad to pull into a kitty city
or a toys r us it was [ __ ] game over
all right because i just said
yeah mom said i couldn't have the super
soakers go really where the [ __ ] is
kitty city vatican
[Laughter]
i missed it what are you saying the
vatican why are you asking me like he's
not here
what the [ __ ] yeah i sound like uncle
junior what do you say yeah
what do you say gang let's talk about
our good friends over there at
stamps.com i tell ya
it's the middle of the summer the last
thing i want to do is wait around in the
post office
and now i ain't got it nah standing
there like a bozo
stand in there like a bazoo stamps.com
you can mail and ship
directly from your office your home
wherever
they save businesses thousands they've
saved thousands of businesses
a lot of cash oh yeah serious case time
money
everything money effort everything tell
em kippy
yeah guys we use it here they sent us
the whole package the printer
uh they set you up they give you even
credits when you sign up
it's easy peasy we send out all the
decks of cards and thousands of decks
of cards out using it it's awesome you
hook it up to the computer bing bang
boom you can print it all you need
is a printer a computer and the internet
that's all you need i don't care if
you're in your car if you're in your
mom's attic the basement the shed
whatever you're doing it's easy the
print was easy
putting them on was easy throw them in a
bag
take them to the post office we made a
day welcome in we're out we're out in
and out 30 seconds you can set up a
pickup if you want to
it's easy peasy guys it's a no brainer
they save nearly a million small
businesses owners
uh small business owners time and money
um you can save up to 40
of usps and up to 66 off shipping rates
uh from ups
i mean what are we doing here stop
wasting time by going to the post office
go to stamps.com instead there's no risk
with our promo code garbage
you've got a special offer that includes
a four-week trial plus free postage and
a digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
big man how about that
last thing you want to do is sign a
contract just go to stamps.com click the
microphone at the top of the home page
type in garbage
at stamps.com promo code garbage gang
let's talk about one of our absolutely
favorite sponsors
talking about fume baby oh yeah canadian
maid
wooden inhaler absolutely fantastic no
chemicals no electronics
nada great nicotine alternative
great for relaxation great for just
chilling out
great for the oral fixation yeah feels
good in your hand you can have in your
hand you're taking a little pull someone
says
ale you vaping you say nah it's fuel i'm
fuming dog
boom yeah uh they sent us a whole bunch
of them we use it
i try to only smoke i got to get off the
if you're smoking burnies long term what
are you doing you know you gotta you
gotta kick it at some point you know
what i mean
give hume a shot they sent us a bunch i
we're at the studio instead of me
running down
having ziggy's you know what i mean
between episodes after i
right here got this we got this sitting
on a desk we hit it takes the edge off
forget about it feels good smells good
nothing gross nothing sticky check out
their conker conquer cure it's a number
one core for sm
for quitting smoking from start to
finish plus a great taste too they got a
unique minty earthy sweet flavor
they use black pepper peppermint and
lavender uh to
ease the nicotine cravings you know he's
the pain of quitting
menthol for a little cool flavor you
know what i mean
so head to breathefume.com that's
breathefumefum.com use our promo code
garbage
or the link will be in the description
of this episode make sure you let them
know we sent you by using our promo code
for 10
off your order today head to
breathfume.com that's breathefumefum.com
click on the link in the description use
promo code garbage ten percent off
now back to the show that's pretty good
it was a toy store
i guess it might have been a more
regional like like i don't know
you know kb yes yeah yeah yeah we had
toys r us
yeah it was a toys r us to get my mom to
do something like that like
on a whim unless there was like a reason
it was my birthday or something like
that
i would have had to grab the wheel on
the highway to get her to turn in this
oh yeah no your birthday's coming up no
quick i was also with you then she'd
hook it up would your parents do i could
like
leverage a birthday like my birthday was
in august yeah but if i
if i was good if i was smooth enough at
making the deal i could get my birthday
present in like january
yeah she would forget that she bought me
the rollerblades or whatever in january
and i double down on my birthday again
my parents patreon.com folks
my parents were always the ones that
knew what i wanted and got me a worse
version
really always every single time i
remember when i was rollerblades
reminded me and this is still one of the
moments i'm like
most embarrassed about as a kid like i
think back to my behavior and i
legitimately get uncomfortable
because the one gift i wanted and i had
no idea my parents were going through
like financial problems probably
you know they hated each other and i had
no idea
but you know my dad was losing his shirt
in the market
no clue and i remember one christmas i
get down and we've had great christmases
filled with boxes
all this stuff like real spectacle and i
get down and there's like six
envelopes on a carpet and i'm like what
the [ __ ] i was like all i wanted
was rollerblades and you pieces of [ __ ]
couldn't even get me rollerblades i'm
like screaming at them
wrestling promo i feel so awful about it
now and my mom was like actually we got
you a gift certificate so you can pick
them out yourself
all right that's good but of course
gonna go now gift certificate
for 50 less than the ones that i like
and the ones that i wanted were base
level because i knew
what they would spend sure and it was 50
less than the base level so i had to get
like some old ass
mom in line still got your shoes on
they're strapped over your shoes
[Laughter]
and my mom was like yeah just make sure
you have enough left over for wrist
guards
like this sucks make sure you wear your
cup mikey
um yeah my parents would do that too but
i tell you what as a kid
it was such a tough look though like i
remember like i asked for a skateboard
one year and they got me like
you remember the nash company nash
plastics yeah yeah it was
garbage i mean the [ __ ] trucks it was
like this they were all plastic there
was
no way that was cal door skateboards
yeah no way
it was a toy it wasn't a skateboard it
was a toy yes yeah they got it for me i
was just like yeah
that's great i think well i think i
might even said this on
the on your first step the first episode
i didn't know anything about
i wanted to be a skateboarder so i got a
nash board yeah
and i was like talking to this kid who
knew in school who knew about
skateboarding
what kind of trucks do you have and i'm
like i don't know man he's like you
gotta get
venture trucks or whatever he was like
saying brands i didn't know i was
[ __ ] independent
yeah i didn't know what he was talking
about i hadn't had a ccs magazine yet
and uh oh my god remember that
road house wasn't that a guy he was like
he was like a he was a big
uh or was that a company birdhouse was a
company i know but there was a kid that
used to let he was like a 16 year old
phenom when ccs was out and
his name was roadhouse or something like
those old school small circulation
magazines whatever it was about they
were [ __ ] awesome they're the best
they were so cool but i went into the
local skate shop that was called g-spot
and it was a purple building on the side
of the highway called jesus i had no
idea a bunch of kids
marching into the jesus dude no idea my
mom's like
my mom looking back she refused to say
the name of the store she would call it
the purple store oh wouldn't it be
uncomfortable if they beckoned you in
like
this right this way come look at our
wheels bearings and more
dads don't believe it exists yeah my dad
never took me
let's keep missing the door hit the wall
[Laughter]
coming through the upstairs i'm sorry
but i was like
yeah i'm looking for trucks like well
what do you have now and i'm like i'm
not sure
and he's like you got ventures
independence crux what do you got i'm
like i don't know
and then i saw the guy behind the
counter realize i don't know what the
he's like you have a nash and i go yeah
that's what i have he goes yeah none of
these work on that that's like a toy and
i was like
i will be leaving now dude i was like it
was a quiet ride home
oh well thanks i appreciate that and
good luck at community college
[ __ ] loser every single mean thing
you've ever said about a skateboarder is
stems from you getting a shitty
skateboard as a kid yeah just put that
together and it's incredible 100 percent
yeah whatever hippie cut your hair and
get a job will you t-bone
i'll give my parents credit on this when
i was four years old
i got a 1989 m1 mongoose bmx
because my favorite movie was rad that
has shaped his life from yeah from that
legitimately like gave me an
appreciation for for bmx for that movie
for everything like i was an
outdoor cat turn your kid yeah and that
that like they really [ __ ] hit a home
run with that one a nice win
when you there's kids that get that [ __ ]
hand it to them
and they don't really appreciate it but
when you catch a win like that
and like you realize what not having i
mean it's silly
you know it's materialistic but you you
realize
you could see the difference in not
having confidence to all of a sudden
having confidence
then you realize what confidence is
feels really good
yeah you know what i mean yeah that's
100 right you put dudes on your pegs
[Laughter]
i was thinking about that the other day
is that do you remember getting you
remember falling off your bike when you
were a kid
and like thinking that like you this was
it you were dying
you ever had a situation like that um i
mean i've had
i've had a couple situations where i've
gotten in horrific accidents but i think
like
i just had entitlement to life like i
didn't think
i didn't think my little white heart
didn't break
until i was like in college and out
that's when my parents got a divorce
that's when a bunch of my friends died
that's when my dog died my grandpa died
like
[ __ ] fell apart and life got real and
before that i was kind of like
no you just get injured and bounce back
up yeah you break an arm or something
yeah
i hadn't crossed that bridge and one
time i got hurt like i i didn't
i didn't break anything i didn't wasn't
a concussion i just fell and it hurt
real like i fell over my handlebars
and like the fear it scares you yeah and
i remember laying there like telling the
guys like i'm not gonna make it man i'm
not gonna make it
i can see the big mcdonald's in the sky
[Laughter]
the drive-through is wide open
[Laughter]
come on henry we're going to heaven oh
man good stuff all right let's get into
some
patriotic questions sure here on our
little podcast episode company episode
sure i messed up i'm trying to cover it
up sure i could tell
thanks for helping me out weird vibe i
love
friend like you know friends that you
know outside of their business and then
you have to watch them in there like
interact yeah you have to be like be
professional
it's hilarious because i know the friend
in you is just like
what are you doing but you're like
to keep the show moving it's called a
segway
[Laughter]
a terrible one that is funny well the
man who created the segway also in the
middle of the podcast who calls it
here on our little podcast i don't know
why you have this kind of energy going
on
because i lost my words i'm [ __ ]
flying without a net here i don't know
what i'm doing
i could have saved it with some editing
but you were real dick earlier
and we're back so the hippie comment
didn't go over well
now we'll watch you burn
i've never seen my parents at work for
the first time and that was like an eye
opener like watching
like my mom deal with a customer and
stuff like that yeah [ __ ]
where did she work never mind she was a
[ __ ]
you left me like i decided not to make a
joke i was gonna say like a hooker or a
strip or something then you were saying
where a customer was involved
i had to choose like four different
times not to call your mom a [ __ ] you
just watched her clean off the corner of
her mouth with her tip
i love you patty you're watching okay
you like the skateboard
sorry pat that's so funny yeah
that this was referring when she was the
manager at the gap
oh okay at the wyoming valley mall we're
talking circa 1983.
before it was the big letters it was
little lowercase gap lowercase cap
nice old school holy [ __ ] yeah all right
i i went to i went to my father's work
when i was uh
when i was younger and like a couple
times and he was in he was a stock
broker
and what i didn't see on the floor down
here no so he was
he was down here but he was uh he did
not work on the floor
he was in midtown he was in he was in
the chrysler building at the end
nice but then he i think he was down
there at some point but he was in the
pumping dumpster
so he was like that's how like everybody
broke in you pass your series seven you
get into that you make an
otherworldly amount of money before you
get caught and then whatever happens
happens yeah
i i don't know if i created this memory
from them retelling me
or if i was there for this but i have a
vivid image in my head
of my father's work partner being carted
out by the fbi
while i was like sitting on his desk and
my legs were really
kicking back like you shred these papers
quit sitting there like an [ __ ] get
to the shredder i couldn't say anything
because i had a bunch of receipt stuff
to my mouth
there's a ink all over my face quick
mikey sign these papers you own this
please
[Laughter]
obviously it's him it's my boy i'm sorry
that's why he gets her parents kids
can't that's fine against their parents
good stuff uh yeah guys so as you know
when you join the uh patreon we will
answer your questions
on air uh it's just the best way to do
it we get so many submissions
uh so we got a couple of heated this one
i talked i rarely go over the questions
with anybody but it was me and t-bones
in there this was a deep cut that you
might not get you're a little older but
this is from ian ever play a cd on your
playstation 2.
oh wow remember that that was a bad look
if you guys were all sitting around the
tv
watching a blue screen listening to like
the foo fighters or something
so two things yes at a party yeah
at it for the party and no because my
parents wouldn't let me get a video game
system
really so i was not a video game kid
really to the point where even still
like i bought myself again a playstation
4 because i deserve it not even
so you don't know what would you could
you you guys are the same age what do
you guys have i didn't have sega
sega was the sega was the big one for
like my like nintendo with when you were
saying
genesis are you 85 uh 86. okay i'm 85.
so yeah so sega was like when i was like
eight nine ten with sega and then
uh n64 came on the [ __ ] scene and
that blew
everything out of the wall yeah then
playstation one
then playstation one kind of took a run
with it and then playstation when
playstation two came out and then
xbox yeah and then nothing i did dream
cat like i i
my friend had a dreamcast and he let me
borrow it and my parents found it and
they like threw it away
so i had to pay i'm holding it for a
friend yeah i didn't
care they threw it away it was insane
but even now like that's why i don't
think they're religious or anything no
they just thought it like wasn't good
for me
so they had really foresight into the
virtual job future
so it's okay to fleece a mailman out of
his life savings
dude my kid can't play donkey kong my
barber
it became like town news and i think my
dad like actually tried to help
are you not nerd without a playstation
he tried to get him to invest
in the stock market but my dad ended up
i think losing
my barber's life savings and this guy
was like 65
70 years old old dude life savings
and i didn't know why everybody didn't
like me in that barber shop
after that but it was because of that i
only found out like five years ago
oh you always got a shitty haircut yeah
yeah why do you always [ __ ] the back of
my neck up
you know ask your piece of [ __ ] father
kids
yikes yeah that's a tough look tough
anything on the tv is tough because for
a while when uh
when cable you know when cable has the
music channels yes
yes and you're pumping those at a party
my mom's big on that oh
music choice cheesy hold on 804 it's the
country music
or whatever yeah god it's bad well and
it doesn't even have like a lava lamp
screen
or anything fun it just has the flat ass
name
yeah yeah yeah it just says like country
music or whatever it just says the type
the genre of music what was the thing
that you said you guys [ __ ] with
party box or something where you would
call in the box
do you remember the box no so the box
was like and and it was remember when
mtv2 was just
music it was like mtv is going to be
like the show's mtv2 was just music
it was before that and it was it was the
box and you would call up a number
and you could request like each
video had its own code so like a britney
spears was 3201 so you called
up [ __ ] and now looking back it's the
most insane any single
at any given time there was probably 4
000 people requesting
hit me baby one more time and you're
like oh they played mine
meanwhile there's 30 000 kids on the
east coast being like yeah we just took
a dollar from each of you
[ __ ] bozos and it was a dollar each
time
and that's yeah it was the box and
that's what you would do and it just
played the world it played like top 40
hacks
did you have to mail them cash no i
think it just like charged your phone or
something oh
man or something like your phone bill i
don't know what happen
first of all let me go through let me go
on the record we didn't have the channel
at my house and
i was definitely not allowed to we only
did it at a friend's house
oh that would be we did it the kid who
was like real new money who like you
were sitting in this house you're like
this is going to come crumbling down at
any given time
and it did i remember my aunt mary
she came to visit and like they never
came over but
she she was the mother of two of my
favorite cousins because they were the
older boys they taught me all
you know everything beat the [ __ ] out of
me playing basketball all that stuff
and so it was always great to have her
over and i remember
she brought a vhs tape of the right said
fred up
video i'm too sexy yeah and i remember
walking in while they were watching it
and they're like get out you can't watch
this what are you doing but i heard the
song and i was like kind of like dancing
yeah
yeah yeah i spent the rest of the
weekend there
going through their luggage looking for
that tape to try to play it
who had the tape the the boys or the mom
the mom she had the vhs she had the vhs
of the video and she was showing people
like like it was viral like you gotta
you gotta see this yeah that's what he
had to do back it was hand-to-hand
combat i don't even remember buying
there was no copying links and forwarded
it she definitely taped it
oh so taped it over all my children
she bought a music video vhs that's what
i thought
oh my god no but the truth yeah that is
exactly what i thought
um all right this one's from johnny ever
been to a wedding that with no open bar
cash bar at a wedding tough luck i have
i've never been i feel it's
yes yeah i have i've i've also had cash
bar at a funeral which [ __ ] sucks
yeah that makes you feel really bad for
everybody involved
yeah it's like the dead person is the
luckiest out of everybody
that you sleep through this [ __ ] you get
to miss it um but yeah i i think
some some wedding i went to which of
course it's always the one that you
aren't even looking forward to yeah
that's the one you're forced or drinking
do they have to say cash bar
what do you mean like would it say like
reception at
300 3rd street you know east 3rd street
i think and then parentheses you say
cash bar right
usually they do yeah okay on the invite
i would want i would want a heads up of
hey
when you get here it's a cash bar yeah
i'd be like thanks for the invite i'm
busy i will drink cheaper in my living
room yeah yeah
why would i would i come to see what
you're going to fail at in two years
[Laughter]
i've never been to just don't have a
wedding
right that's the case no i mean i've had
like i i've been to
every shape and size wedding there is i
did coke
and acid at like a um it was acid at a
wedding
well and it was it was a ve what is the
word i'm looking for because very jewish
is not correct orthodoxy yeah so it
wasn't hasidic it was like the notch
below
where you know everybody's still in all
the garb but it was just for that
special occasion they're fantastic
weddings though
oh my god it was so fun the food was
incredible you know
that i could taste from all the drip
going down my esophagus
but i took such a little bit of acid
that it just made me
into the greatest dancer of all time
you're doing acid and coke at the same
time yeah i wouldn't recommend it bam
but uh it was fun fun little sliver of
acid and then a couple pick-me-ups
throughout the evening you know what i
mean
i could see yeah and then i lost like
the kid's coke like at some point he was
like hey you went to the bathroom with a
get it back i was like yeah sorry pal
pat me down i have no idea what happened
to it yeah i've told that story i have
an idea what happened to it
[Laughter]
the cops came in man you didn't see him
leaving
lodged that bullet for you huh good
stuff
um all right this one's from gary has
your eerie has your tv
ever been too big for your living room
yes have you ever like yeah mm-hmm
we have my first apart my first
townhouse to me and my buddy after
college
i'm like this is what we're doing we
spent i don't know like twenty seven
hundred dollars on a flat screen
at the time that we didn't have the
money oh for so it was flat
yeah oh okay yeah it was like i mean it
was like a [ __ ] 170 inch tv
or something in a 10 by 10 room what did
you think it was a regular tv so
so i had a mine was at my wife's first
apartment but it was our tv and we were
going to bring it into where
ever we moved in after but it was a flat
screen
but not a flat
[ __ ] and the stand was forever soldered
on
yeah so it was like a fire 175 pounds
yeah it took me and like six of my
gorilla friends to [ __ ] even shimmy
it in this things were
was it wood it was no it was it was gray
plastic
but it was so wood what the [ __ ] you
don't remember those
of course i do but not with flat screens
no they were well it was the big the
huge big screens
yes instead of being plastic before they
were plastic when wood was still in it
it's not [ __ ] it's not a 2x4 or
something it's like i know what you're
talking about it's like
a big flat screen tv yeah yeah we called
them flat screens yeah we called them
big screen
to us that was a big screen right and it
was one of those apartments where like
you had to create the second room
sure you know like so it was a fake wall
and so and i think like we got it in and
smashed through the fake wall
like instantly they had to pay 1800
bucks to get it repaired it was just an
insane
inconvenience for everybody oh that's
garbage we moved in here they're like
yeah you can put a wall
in here i'm like yeah that's what i want
to do make it smaller you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
he's like we can split this up any way
you want i'm like yeah okay
i want to ask you did they ever leave
you anywhere when you were a kid you
ever get forgotten anywhere yeah
yeah i think it may have happened at cal
door to be particularly
honest uh well i'm just i'm just took a
rain check on mikey huh
well they so i got lost in a store like
that
where i remember my parents i remember
seeing my mother sprinting
like the whole story like so i was in an
aisle
and i saw her just like she was in the
firm
dude full tom cruise sprint like no
facial express
and i screamed mom and you could like
hear her tires screech on the floor and
she came back
she grabbed me it was like you know half
mad half appreciative
half everything but i uh one of this
happened with my cousin
she was like soda in your hand like my
where you going
what's the what's the hurry staring at a
pair of rollerblades you can't afford it
what i want for christmas
my cousin renee who is now a radicalized
islamist
um that's a relationship yeah it's not
her name anymore so try to find her but
um
judy isn't that weird it's it sounds
her name is is clearing your throat
but um so she uh she convinced
my older sister and i to hide from my
mom
oh it's never good in like the gap or
something where they had those circular
i was just gonna say under the clothes
so you hot you go
that's what that is dude
that is exactly right you're the king of
your castle and that
you call the shots
yeah you decide when to come and go
and yeah i think i i heard my mom's
voice trembling screaming trying to find
her kids running out into the mall and
my cousin being like not yet yeah hold
it hold it hold it let it really
panicked yeah
we got out and she was like look she's
pumped you're still alive like you are
just just built for evil yeah cause i
was in a bowling alley with my nephew
and uh one of my cousins and his son we
took him took the
kids bowling i ran like eight o'clock on
a saturday night presumed a couple weeks
ago
i didn't think you were waiting to pick
up chicks we got the bombing
we were actually bowling that saturday
night this guy's little but he's 18.
um but then our arcade and all that were
smoking leftover cigarette butts
we hit the arcade and it was pretty
crowded but i was just
curious like they were they were playing
like a jurassic park game
and i was like now out of curiosity
would you if it was just you by
themselves with them would you like go
and like grab a table and wait for them
like to come over he's like absolutely
not
he's like i wouldn't be more than 15
feet from them yeah because
that's how kids disappear yeah so yeah
your mom's probably
when you're a little kid you don't
realize she's worried they're chopping
me up dude even when i'm alone
with myself a dark turn but he's right i
know yeah
even when i'm alone with my son at like
the park right and we're we're playing
the bat
we're playing basketball or whatever
running around and there is nobody there
i always walk backwards to get the ball
and not turn around and leave him on
yeah i make sense
cause it's just too much man i like the
my
my imagination is probably more capable
than
but so i'm just picturing somebody out
of nowhere yoinking this kid up throwing
them in the back of a dodge neon and i
never see him again yeah
i i do i run all those scenarios too
because i'm like well if i was gonna
adopt a kid this is how i would do it
yeah i would wait until the dad turned
around and i would just
yeah yeah i'd see the only idiots in the
park sure and that guy just kind of go
get a rogue ball and this two-year-old
sitting there picking his [ __ ] and
you know yoke him up wrong yeah keep an
eye on him get him taken real quick
let's go kidnapping after this guys
um all right this one's from strong
first time question long time listener
how frequently does your family use
craigslist
for anything we're all getting booker
together
so i think i talked about this on the
last
part of my last last appearance here but
there is a very
specific faction of my family so my
family is very white trash
like you know my dad's from levittown
long island my mother is from jersey
and i grew up in rockland county which
up until recently i thought was like
kind of well to do
that's a dirtbag trifecta right i know
but rocklin like
it's trashy westchester pretty much and
i the guy
uh lucas who comes around with me and
films my [ __ ] is from like
the most insane part of westchester
really wealthy
and kind of exposed how they feel about
us
and i've never felt lower sure about
myself in my entire life and i just i
was like okay so it hits the trifecta i
have three
trash things in a row but my family
tries very hard
to act elitist like we were worth the
well to do
cannons we we go to college that's a big
thing
we found out within like gar it's like
i'm not you
like you just try to separate yourself
yes of what you already recognized when
you're right
like i would never do that i'm wearing a
collared shirt today it's that good
it's that great seinfeld line when he
goes back to he performs a governor
yeah he's just like it's it's everything
you hate about yourself
about yourself staring back deep down
inside you are
you know that's what it is so my uncle
johnny who is no longer with us
he uh his yard was craigslist
like he got everything from craigslist
and also other players that stuff in the
yard that's a tough look
it's a real if you got like just
anything if you're picking up stuff i'll
fix this i can resell that
the guy never fixes or resells the stuff
and it's the classics
it's a tv it's the flamingo
the errant flamingo a car on cinder
blocks
a tractor yeah furniture like all that
[ __ ] and then you go in it like he
furnished my first elmhurst queen's
apartment
with stuff he found you know wherever
yeah acquired
yeah but my family's always like like
that's that's them
so we are yeah we're amazon people
be nice not prime but we're amazon
people yeah
foley's on the other hand we knew we
were trash yeah jump street yeah we
we knew the deal it's a better way yeah
you embrace it embrace it and keep it
moving and i'll say this
i have never used craigslist for
anything other than nefarious purposes
no [ __ ] i won't say what they are but
i've never bought anything off of
craigslist
yeah not in the sense you're thinking
about you've rented things off
craigslist
i uh i had a three-week jaunt on
craigslist
romantic encounters when i first got off
of college and i was like trying to find
day work while
pursuing stand-up sure and there was a
couple of girls that i was going to meet
up with but each one had
like just something that didn't smell
right you know what i mean like
and i talked to this girl she sent me
pictures all this stuff beautiful like
light-skinned black chick
and we were gonna meet in in in uh
manhattan and like see a movie like you
know neutral zone
and last minute she's like i can't come
out i got a dick yeah she's like will
you come out to jamaica queens and i was
like
nope yeah no i very much will not she's
like it's not bad here i was like oh
yeah i have the get richer die trying
album
so it's gonna be my favorite yeah i'm
gonna go ahead and uh just go by what
i've learned
i can come out to jamaica queens but the
question is will i ever leave
that's right that's the problem yeah hot
chick ah come to my house yeah
i i once posted on the craigslist free
section
i'm poor buy me a pizza and two people
sent me free pizzas no [ __ ] oh yeah
well yeah recently no oh
not as interesting as sex with strangers
but i like you
[Laughter]
be honest with you that's the most
stunning thing i've ever heard out of
your mouth
[Laughter]
pizza is not as exciting uh i remember
the first time i found out what
miss connections was yeah dude that was
oh yeah you know miss connections
miss connections missed connections on
craigslist you know
missed miss miss yeah where
hey you bought me pizza two weeks ago i
need some wings
i like cheese fries chicago deep dish
zany's old town rosemary
johnny o'halligan's the best comedian
when i was like 20 i posted
he gave it all to me right there he went
off topic a little bit t-bone i
apologize
when i was like 20 i posted a t-bone how
to fight
we both have very aggressive
negotiations yeah
t-bone was up for a raise and i played
hardball in the in the board room
it wasn't a race what do you want we
have no money
what do you want this whole thing's a
shampoo
money you have 150 actual patrons and
then everything else is reinvested
see the money's in the licenses toby
you find 10 more patrons they find 10
more people
you got to stake nice quit bitching
we have 20 patreon members and 1600
emails
i'm just kevin ryan wanted gmail kevin
ryan too with gmail come right through
gmail that's too good oh i posted it in
the
men's seeking women my 20 year old then
current headshot
nice how to do it and miss connections
i thought miss connections was like hey
i saw you in the bus i thought you were
wearing a green sweater
i was uh you know wearing a blue hat we
made eye contact
yeah i got really into that for a little
while like just reading them or
yeah reading them it was sultry did
anybody ever get back to each other do
you think anybody ever
i think that stuff is fair use you
should make a coffee table book
your favorite one yeah i really i got
into it
more like a bathroom book if you know
what i mean
i used to eyebrow please i remember the
gentleman in rockland county
hello i remember remember
the only time that i've written an ad on
craigslist uh oh this isn't true but a
personal ad i used to write ads for like
comedy shows or whatever
but um i uh i remember when ghana beat
united states in the world cup
might have been like oh wait like that
or maybe even 2010
whatever it was i just remember that i
was so pissed off about it i
wrote an advertisement on craigslist
challenging
any random guyanese person to a
one-on-one soccer match
in the park of their choice do you play
soccer yeah
yeah just never pick up something [ __ ]
this
i'm i'm taking it back i gotta get back
i don't even have a camera like it's not
like i was doing it for content i was
doing it for
american pride and jesus
nerd alert a soccer game uh
i sold uh i sold my snowboard when i was
in college i needed cash and i was like
oh you know
it was like i don't know 300 snow or
whatever like it was like i was like oh
i don't go anymore if i go i can just
rent again or whatever
and so i sold it to this dude i met he
was from south philly
like stereotypical he pulls up white
escalade gets out
like wife beater tucked into like the
black jeans or whatever
chain watch and i'm like ah this dude is
just like
he's either in the mob or wants you to
think he's in the mob
either way it's like he's hitting all of
the notes he's trying to hit though
and he's like dude [ __ ] juice head
like [ __ ] jacked and he's like
i'm this short fat kid and i like open
up the trunk he's like yeah i'm like oh
200 right he's like yeah 150
and i'm like nah it's 200 he's like
that's 150. i go all right we'll do 150.
i'll see you later see you later sir
you give him the board and the money
hey why did i drive you up the mountains
let's go you look like you'll enjoy this
more than me good stuff yeah i really
bitched out
i believe it the [ __ ] does that supposed
to mean
what were you doing on a [ __ ]
snowboard anyway a little fat kid with a
dumb haircut i was
a good snowboarder no kidding yeah do
you still know how you still go
yeah well i uh i shattered my uh
wrist quite bad and then i had like the
erectors did you ever see like the
halo you get yeah i've had that i had
that coming out of my arm oh [ __ ]
yeah but you didn't do it snowboarding
right
yeah i did i thought you fell off the
couch or something like this i thought
that's what you told me you two don't
know each other at all
this is this is all [ __ ] you got
pushed out of a treehouse
no that italian guy from south philly
beat me up
uh yeah and then i just never went i'm
like yeah it was like
i was like i'm too old to be fault-like
oh dude i went
this winter with sagalow and phoenix and
we filmed a thing for it and
i try i i'm not like i saw the video
yeah i'm not like a real snowboarder but
i am an athlete so
i like try to grab off of a box for some
reason
and i the video makes it look like i got
eight inches off the ground i
felt like i was flying sure i felt like
a
pure goose like just in the air and i
landed
directly on my coccyx like every
inch of force hit the tailbone of my ass
and it just like lightning shot up my
spine and i couldn't like
walk right for a few for like a week and
a half yeah you've been there
you get to a point where craigslist
again
you get to a point you're just too old
to be falling you're talking about a
misconnection
that's like jesus christ toby
don't look over me i ain't saving you i
was looking over for disapproval
oh i got that today the toe was going
all right let's do one or two more
this one's just i i mean foley you'll
have to wait on this uh this is from
eric
um does your family probably an exercise
question yeah
does your family eat something so weird
that everyone thinks is nuts but you
love it we do a cinnamon bread mayo and
oscar meyer bologna sandwich
wow that just nothing about that seems
it's too much
relatively okay but you think that but i
i completely understand what she's
talking about i love that you are
you're like the john nash of food
because i watched you put together the
algorithm in front of your eyes
and you just tasted cinnamon on the
right part of your tongue you got a
little mayo here and then a dollop
an outline of cinnamon the bread popped
up and then bologna
i thought you were talking about the
nets coach i was like where's he going
with this
steve nash oh my god i do have a pretty
good jumper
he's aged foley from a beautiful stomach
[Laughter]
i used to do just mayo sandwiches it
makes my blood run cold dude on a uh
unlike a hamburger bun like the white
hamburger bun you throw a slice of
tomato on there a little salt and pepper
it's clean living
that's class like yeah that to me is a
nice little
why just mayo that's all that was in
there or no i just like i just like
but the thing but the odd thing that i
really think is normal and everybody
that has watched me do it
is like kind of disgusted but it doesn't
make sense i pour
milk in my ice cream so every time that
i have ice cream
i put it in a tall pint glass and then i
you know stack it to the top and then
pour milk in it
and it like kind of freezes the ice
cream in an interesting way and it turns
it into a
half half milkshake half like almost
crystallized ice cream
that's insane awesome have you ever met
anybody else that does that no i am so
lactose intolerant also so i just
bazooka blood out of my ass right
about doubling down on the dairy this
guy yeah i am lactose intolerant
let's kick it up a notch i was gonna
start [ __ ] on you but then the way
you described that
doesn't sound i get it i get it but it's
like that's a that's intense
it's like a white trash bloody mary i
also to put a polio string cheese as
garnish
you got a twizzler straw hot wheels
garnish on it
um i i'll do that with uh try it i
implore everybody before
before you judge try it out i'll do that
with soda
it's legitimately [ __ ] soda i'm talking
milk all right do milk
in ice cream i'm telling you it's great
okay i like it
i can't you wouldn't do it no no shot
that's insane
yeah i mean like it's made of milk it's
not he's not
pouring mustard on it it makes sense
it's not that far
to say no shot you could give it a whirl
yeah
kick that orange juice and cereal i
refuse i will not drink milk i refuse oh
you're not a male guy oh
really no shot really no shot now why is
that do we know that story
were you breastfed what's up were you
breastfed yeah your mom was great oh
that's rude
toblerone
[Laughter]
shout out to toby t-bone's been running
a little thin
[Laughter]
that one that toblerone goes back to
like high school as he called that
nice nice well i can't call you that
what's with the milk weirdo
it's just gross milk is disgusting it's
no good it tastes like [ __ ]
well that's crazy talk i mean even in
cereal
almond milk dude oh almond milk oh yeah
oh toby i don't like your tongue man
what your tongue tastes things weird
[Laughter]
gentlemen's making great points i've
never heard something
so straightforward and blunt your tongue
tasting is weird almond milk and cereal
that sounds real commie to me
yeah that sounds like i don't think so
some real
defund the police
[Laughter]
where's
[Laughter]
when you gotta start the day with the
healthy breath
before you go deep before you get maced
reach for almond milk reach for almonds
strawberry special
she's got one bruise from a billy club
right across her forehead
dude you know look those rubber bullets
they hurt like a [ __ ] oh yeah i
think they've been known to kill a
person they're also called bullets
i mean yeah you know what they call them
back in the 1700s
bullets musket balls
i like that your take from all that all
the riots all the news man those rubber
bullets look like they're not [ __ ]
like they stink
they'd probably leave a welt or
something those water cannons are they
saltwater fresh water
is that distilled or what are we talking
hanks what's going on here
dude now that that is like i scored it
with seltzer
i got a little long i gotta get a hit of
lime over here
that's what the french police used
pellegrinos
all right wrap it up ah gang we love you
mikey thank you so much for coming and
sitting with us please check out the
irish goodbye podcast
what else you have coming up let the
folks know oh yeah i got here's the
scenario is our other podcast that's me
feeney and sagilaw we got a patreon as
well patreon.com scenariopod
we do a ton of bonus footage as well i
just put a heads-up poker match between
me and robert kelly
up on there and i do a web series called
mike takes edibles where i take edibles
and check in with the
audience very fun the course of the
experience pretty fun you know if you
guys like to do edibles on camera i
would love to have you both on
i'd love to do it yeah hell yeah be it
oh yeah you do love edibles i do love
animals
on camera i gave you a healthy dose and
you just chomped it down with no
problem he's uh he was smoking a joint
upstairs at the penthouse
and we were doing a show and it was like
right after covet and i was like are you
feel comfortable sharing that i'll take
a little hit and he's like nah he's like
i'm taking it to my head but i have a so
i put it i told you this story four
times
but we have a piece i have a piece of an
edible a just
a piece of an edible is what he said i
have a piece of an edible downstairs
that you can have
okay thanks go downstairs he hands me
this little
brick like that it's halfway on the
outfit he goes oh be careful that's a
hundred milligrams
a hundred what do you mean
what's a milligram i feel like i'm in
cal door
[Laughter]
what do you got uh as always please make
sure you rate if you subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube
patreon.com and guys the live shows will
be coming to
a city near you i'm mikey was that it
we're diving
today no yeah patreon patreon the
youtube my canon comedy it's got all
that [ __ ] and then my tour dates are at
mikecanoncomedy.com coming to chicago in
october
fantastic chicago yeah i'm doing a doing
a whole run i mean there's
a lot more dates coming in so check it
out my check out mike i'm sure most of
you know mikey because
you know you know us but if you don't
you gotta check him out he's [ __ ] one
of the best
we appreciate you 100 kippy we just did
this
we just did this kibo man this guy's on
goofballs today
mikey kevin oh man goodbye everybody
peace
oh that was great good stuff so fun